I hope I shall always possess firmness
and virtue enough to maintain what I
consider the most enviable titles the
character of an honest man George
Washington once wrote to a young
Alexander Hamilton as well as to prove
he added what I desire to be considered
in reality that I am good evening I'm
Matthew Spalding the associate vice
president and Dean of educational
programs for Hillsdale College here in
Washington DC welcome to the kirby
center for constitutional studies and
citizenship relationship between virtue
and statesmanship as the quote from vet
washington attests is central to the
very idea of citizens statesmen what are
those virtues that are central to that
true greatness this evening I must say
we are very pleased proud really though
I'd have to say humbly proud or perhaps
proudly humble to host the book launch
of our colleague David Bob to formally
introduce dr. Bob please welcome miss
Tori Cooney Tony to notorious from
Louisville Kentucky it's currently a
senior at Hillsdale where she is
majoring in English she has involved in
many things on campus opera jazz the
history honoring as you might expect she
is a good writer from what I can tell
she is in our journalism program and as
a staff writer for the Student Paper the
collegian I have been subjected to her
hard and difficult interviews and can
attest to her prowess and keep in mind
that my comments are off the record
Tory's here in the whip program is
currently interning for humanities which
is the magazine of the National
Endowment for the Humanities
I would also like to welcome you all to
the kirby center and i have the honor of
introducing you to david j Bob he's the
executive director of citizen education
for hillsdale college and a lecture in
politics I get to read that one he's
also the founding director of two
national centers for Hillsdale this one
fondly known as the alan p Kirby jr.
center for constitutional studies and
citizenship but also the Hoogland center
for teacher excellence a civic education
program in addition to that he's a
contributing editor to the US
Constitution a reader has written an
astounding number of topics for an
astounding array of national
publications that include the Wall
Street Journal the Washington Times Fast
Company and the claremont in Review of
Books and he has spoken to audiences in
25 states so pressures on he received
his BA from Hillsdale College and his
PhD in political science from Boston
College and so I humbly introduce David
Jay Bob
thank you very much Tori thank you Matt
and thank you all for being here this
evening it's wonderful to see so many
friends and colleagues who are dedicated
to keeping pride in its proper place
it's a hard thing to do especially here
in Washington DC to check humility at
the door last I investigated the
humility caucus in Congress lacked it's
still seeking a quorum there's actually
a lot of humility talk these days and of
course a lot of it comes from
politicians ever noticed that the
loudest exclamations of humility come on
election day in winning his US Senate
seat recently in the state of New Jersey
Cory Booker just pledged himself to what
he called the quote hard humble work of
that office US House Speaker John
Boehner upon assuming that office talked
a number of times in that speech about
how important it was to recover humility
although it wasn't an election day
President Barack Obama on the National
Day of Prayer in 2013 spoke about how we
as a nation and as individuals need to
recover the virtue of humility the more
we talk about humility however the more
arrogant and arrogance we seem to see
all around us in the recent book about
Washington insiders this town author
mark Leibovich who is the new york times
chief national correspondent uses more
than 20 references phrases really that
begin with the word self let me give you
a couple of the examples self inflated
self intoxication self reverential
self-dealing the list goes on and on and
on in an era of selfies me note speeches
remember chris Christie's speech at the
republican national convention right a
keynote that turned into a me note and
an overwhelming culture of narcissism
self-absorption and self-promotion
we can't help but wonder whether we're
living today in an age of arrogance this
reminds me before I go any further into
my brief remarks this evening my
publisher Thomas Nelson which is part of
HarperCollins wanted me to offer a
message to you all I better do this
before I forget it please follow me on
Twitter like me on Facebook pinned me on
pinterest take an Instagram photo of me
take a photo of the book for Instagram
take a photo of yourself for Instagram
send a vine about me connect with me via
Google+ then and only then send me your
Klout score so that I should see if I
should have anything to do with you
based upon your online influence
actually my publisher has been wonderful
and i do want to before saying anything
else express my gratitude to my editor
joel miller and his colleagues heather
sexton kim boy boyer emily lineberger
and everyone else at Thomas Nelson who
has brought this book into existence as
long as I'm offering thanks I I must
mention and gladly mentioned the
wonderful contribution of my wife Anna
who's standing in the back not only is
she
she's an exacting editor immovable and
rigorous but loving in every other way
about the time that we were finishing up
this volume a few months ago our two
boys were were delighted at the prospect
of it being done the older one for said
to the younger to that what we should do
in celebration this was in the in the
winter months what we should do in
celebration is start a fire as big as
daddy's head now I don't know really
where this came from and whether or not
my son was trying to tell me something I
can assure you I think that there is no
ironclad 12-step program for becoming
humble there might not be a 12-step
program or plan but that didn't stop
benjamin franklin from coming up with
what was really a kind of thirteen part
planned for what he called moral
perfection let me say just a few words
about that and by way of introduction to
to james madison and frederick douglass
the two figures that i wanted to focus
on this evening so Franklin as a
twenty-something looked about his life
and saw a lot of disorder he saw a lack
of frugality a kind of a lot of time
wasting around his endeavors and he
sought to go about a rigorous way of
becoming a better human being he pulled
together 12 different virtues like
temperance silence order resolution
frugality and the list went on that he
was going to systematically work on if
he made a mistake in one of those if he
heard and would did not live up to the
high standard that he was setting he
would mark a little black mark in his
his book now when he drew up this list
he went to a friend of his and said have
I captured the things that I ought to
work on his friend a Quaker said you
know you're kind of arrogant
as Franklin put it he kindly informed me
that I was generally thought proud that
my pride showed itself frequently in
conversations well to his credit
Franklin adopted humility so that he had
a baker's dozen than a virtues to work
on the injunction that he gave to
himself was imitate Jesus and Socrates
an interesting injunction imitate Jesus
and Socrates the humble person must
acknowledge that he is not self-made
North the center of the universe
unblinking self-knowledge reveals our
imperfections humility requires that we
admit when we are wrong and then change
course it's the soul state of
self-knowledge in which we put others
ahead of ourselves in thought word and
deed despite our tendency to self
aggrandizement now what Franklin
realized in the process of going through
this project of sort of moral perfection
was that humility was the one of those
thirteen that most bedeviled him but it
was the one that paid him a great deal
of rewards for as an old man in his 80s
reflecting on what a lifetime of working
on that virtue meant he realized that it
had made him slower to criticize slower
to interject more quick to want to win
the person over and not just prevail in
the argument he realized that there was
something and always something very
important about insisting upon your foul
ability and recognizing but not being
quick to point out the imperfections of
others now there's a kind of dilemma
that he came to though because there's
no real mastery ever of humility as
Franklin put it if I could conceive that
I had completely overcome my pride I
should probably become proud of my
humility you see the dilemma there
Franklin's dilemma was America's dilemma
it still is how to become humble how to
stay humble and at the same time be
great
how do you uphold that achievement of
greatness and maintain humility Muhammad
Ali had his own reflection on that
particular challenge it's hard to be
humble he said when you're as great as I
am humility is hard to achieve even when
you're not the greatest it's more
difficult to be great and humble at the
same time and I think that takes us to
George Washington the person who we
perhaps most associate with the idea of
greatness of soul both he in the
American context and Abraham Lincoln
George Washington we think of though as
a sort of man of pre-made perfection
that's incorrect he was a person that
wrestled with great temptations no one
is naturally humble and it certainly did
not come by nature to George Washington
what he had to do was overcome the
temptation to self aggrandizement as a
young man he wanted renowned he wanted
to be famous he wanted to be the
greatest but in pursuit of power renown
and greatness for its own sake it was
elusive for him it was difficult to
achieve when he reoriented his sights
and set them upon the common good he
realized that then the lasting
achievement of greatness might be
possible he had to beat back his ego
channel it it wasn't as if Washington
ever gave up being ambitious he was
ambitious throughout his life but what
he had to come to was ambition for the
right things for the things that
mattered when he was at the pinnacle of
his power Washington gave it up a real
test of humility when he was at the
Constitutional Convention when things
were not as we now see with that with
hindsight foreordained for success right
when those delegates wandered in the
first month whether in fact they would
succeed in their endeavor having failed
before to amend and change the Articles
of Confederation to put the United
States on a solid foundation Washington
said this we can lay the foundation but
the community at large
must raise the edifice we can raise the
foundation he said of his fellow
founders but the community at large must
raise the edifice what I'd like to talk
about very briefly is how James Madison
can point us to what laying the
foundation means and how Frederick
Douglass in a very different but related
way might help us understand how we can
raise the edifice Madison was as a grown
man not 100 pounds soaking wet he was a
hypochondriac throughout his life and
when he wasn't feigning illness he was
often actually sick he was a man that
stood 5 feet 3 inches in height he had a
small voice when he wasn't taking the
notes like he usually did he wrote the
best notes of the constitutional
convention by far even though there was
a full-time secretary when he wasn't
taking the notes very often there would
be a gap in the records of what Madison
himself was saying for they could not
hear him he spoke so quietly early in
his life and throughout his career
really he was alleged to have been what
the ancients would have called
pusillanimous not really living up to
greatness not living up even to a
reasonable standard of success he was
seen as meek mild week and wimpy kind of
the way that humility is seen today it's
a virtue for wimps that's often the
characterization now Madison was despite
all of this a man of prodigious talent
when he went off to college at the
college of new jersey now princeton he
finished his work in half the normal
time in two years rather than four he
stayed on an extra semester to read
Hebrew his fifth language with the
president of that college the signer of
the Declaration of Independence John
Witherspoon upon completing that study
having driven himself into a state of
exhaustion in that extra semester he
returned to Montpelier where he was
promptly saddled with the
enviable task of tutoring his siblings
he felt like some young people do today
returning to home after graduating from
college like his life had no meaning he
was utterly bored and without a purpose
as he put it he did not quote expect a
long or healthy life he had quote little
spirit and alacrity to set about
anything that is difficult in acquiring
and useless in possessing after one has
exchanged time for eternity end quote in
other words he had no idea what he was
going to do with his life how did he
figure it out well Madison looked around
him and he saw Baptists in the
neighboring county besieged for their
religious belief held in a place where
they could not practice religion freely
by the prevailing established religion
that ignited something in the young
James Madison it set him on a quest to
become the one who would stand in the
gap for people when their rights
god-given rights were trammeled in his
dejected state of mind Madison was
unable to see how well as make up an
education had prepared him for a career
in politics just as the body of a
world-class runner looks as if it is
built for speed Madison's intellectual
form was fitted perfectly for
legislative politics his physical
presence might have been anemic but his
political presence developed over time
was strong his political modus operandi
never relied upon overall power
rhetorical pyrotechnics or charismatic
cajole or rather his way was thorough
study share the results of your studies
and get ahead get out in front of the
debate to come anticipation and timing
are the fast twitch muscles of political
work and Madison succeeded over and over
again in knowing where to be the moment
of political need had risen by the time
he left politics he had served in active
office for more than 30 years his race
was an ultra marathon not a sprint what
did he accomplish in the book I go
through the the really amazing record of
how he and his elder friend and
colleague of eight years Thomas
Jefferson collaborated to bring an end
to that or at least to put on course of
ultimate extinction that religious
bigotry in their home state of Virginia
and in so doing to do that in the rest
of the United States their work which
preceded the adoption of the First
Amendment but also led to it ensured
that religious liberty would be a legacy
for centuries to come in the course of
achieving this monumental accomplishment
Madison displayed an intellectual
humility that says the truth does not
need the backing of the state to win
right you don't need to have an
established religion it's going to be
counterproductive anyway he displayed a
kind of religious humility that says
people should not be coerced into
salvation right by Christianity zone
lights Madison argued it wouldn't make
sense to do it but by point of sword
right why would you do that to to your
fellow citizens thirdly he displayed a
kind of political humility that says the
sovereign cannot repeal conscience and
so it should not try to do so at the end
of his battle that epic battle for
religious liberty in the Commonwealth of
Virginia Madison allowed himself a
little boast it was one that he offered
to Thomas Jefferson in a letter and he
said that their bill for establishing
religious freedom had quote in this
country extinguished forever the
ambitious hope of making laws for the
human mind end quote it took a person
like James Madison to make that kind of
thing happen and in that we see the kind
of statecraft that he put into effect in
the Constitution as a whole that kind of
care every day at the Constitutional
Convention James Madison was there front
and center not only being the third most
talkative right and that's you don't get
credit just for talking right but really
substantive that's what Madison was but
he also recorded the notes he recorded
the conversation and he was ready the
next day again for the debate it was his
foresight in coming to the conclusion
that the Articles of Confederation had
to go that paved the way for the
adoption of the United States
Constitution and in so many ways he
earned the title the father of the
Constitution in that we see the example
of what Washington talked about the
laying of the foundation that foundation
we know was one that I would argue us is
really quite a humble one it was one
that the tot said the government had to
be limited that did not mean that it was
to be weak it was to be limited but
purposeful the things that it was
charged to do in the Constitution it had
to do well it had to be strong mainly to
defend the individual rights of human
beings of all Americans now that takes
us if we can fast-forward then to the
raising of the edifice to Frederick
Douglass you know part of the challenge
of humility and coming to be a humble
person is maintaining a healthy pride
this Madison had to do and also
Frederick Douglass had to do in his own
life for more than any of the other four
characters that are featured in this
book George Washington Abigail Adams
Madison and the Abraham Lincoln you have
in Douglas a man who had to overcome
extraordinary humiliation in the same
year in which Illinois became a state in
which Abraham Lincoln's mother died
Frederick Douglass was born he never
knew for sure the day of his birth or
the month for a while he was even unsure
about the year his best guess was that
he was born in February 1818 officially
his mother named him Frederick Augustus
Washington Bailey he later used the
surname Stanley then
Johnson and then finally Douglas he
added an S at the end after Sir Walter
Scott's poem Lady of the lake and the
figure in that poem he did not know the
identity of his father but it was
probably his first master Aaron Anthony
a white man who served as chief overseer
of properties for Colonel Edward Lloyd
one of maryland's wealthiest men young
Freddie hardly knew his mother who lived
on a neighboring farm and she died
before he turned eight years old his
early years he wrote in one of the three
autobiographies he penned lacked quote
an intelligible beginning he didn't own
his first pair of pants until he was
about seven and in one particularly
gripping incident that he relates into
this early life one of the only
encounters he had with his mother she
came unannounced only to see Douglas
locked in a battle with one of those who
although a fellow slave was charged with
feeding him and she was depriving him of
food Douglas was arguing for his claim
of the day's rations and his mother came
upon this awful scene only to intervene
on his behalf what he wrote is that was
the first time in his life that he ever
felt somebody had pled his case had
stood for justice in his life and it
brought within him the first stirrings
of pride for he felt that somebody cared
about him that his mother actually loved
him now she lived far enough away 13
miles I think it was the ta's in making
that round trip she had to return that
same night it constituted a kind of full
marathon 26 miles of maternal love
slavery what Douglas knew for the first
major part of his life was a
self-perpetuating cycle of disordered
pride and debased conduct what he called
the quote sole Karsh crushing and death
dealing character of slavery end quote
was given rise to buy an arrogance that
wishes others to work for one's own gain
humiliation is the means by which this
end is accomplished let me relate one of
the most
harrowing incidents of the amelie ation
that Douglas bought talked about in his
autobiographies there was an old slave
named old Barney he was about as old as
his imperious owner this is what Douglas
writes these two men were both advanced
in years there were the silver locks of
the master and the bald and toil one
brow of the slave superior and inferior
here powerful and weak here but equals
before God old Barney described by
Douglas as possessing quote a respectful
and dignified bearing was the keeper of
the Lloyd stable along with his son
young Barney obsessed with his horses
the owner was always finding fault with
their care after noting some perceived
infraction of the stable rules by old
Barney Lloyd ordered the old slave to
kneel he then delivered 30 lashes with
his horsewhip Douglas had watched
countless whippings but at this one he
was shocked to see the spectacle of an
aged man and here again I'm quoting from
Douglas a husband and a father humbly
kneeling before his fellow man taking
the lashes patiently with no resistance
responding to each blow with only a
shrug of the shoulders and a groan what
young Freddie Bailey witnessed in that
incident he later said was slavery in
its truest color now you can see for him
that the idea of humility took on in one
sense a very problematic meaning right
for it connoted a kind of humiliation
humility comes from the word that
relates to the earth right humise dirt
to be forced back into that place that's
what Douglas knew he slept on the ground
as a slave what he saw is a pride that
he wanted to be able to have in who he
was he knew that there was a dignity in
him in his mother in that man old Barney
but every day but rest' by theological
arguments he was told that there was
none what he had to do was recapture in
his life that sense of worth he had to
gain at the same time of that he gained
the healthy pride he had to uphold a
humility
now how did he do this well Douglas was
a very intelligent young man and came to
a place where he could help teach
himself even how to read he was also
brought along by the wife of one of his
slave owners when he was sent off to
Baltimore and what happened as he
learned to read was a kind of
intellectual awakening his slave masters
saw that if he learns to read the Bible
his master said in Baltimore II will
forever unfit him to be a slave that's
exactly what Douglas wanted to happen he
wanted to be unfit for slavery when he
read the Bible when he read the book
that meant so much to him that told
tales of people gaining their freedom of
george washington leading this nation
into freedom Douglas realized that there
was something very much higher than his
own existence something that he could
strive for and achieve now what happened
after they realized that he was being
made unfit for slavery is that they sent
him to be broken by the worst slave
raker in the Eastern Shore of Maryland
he had to walk seven miles to this man's
place and at the time he was 16 and he
reflected on how much his own life was
subject to the whims of others where in
the world would Frederick Douglass end
up now what's important to note at this
juncture is that even as he was
beginning to have this intellectual
awakening there was also a moral
stirring in his own life for what he
realized is that if he was going to gain
his liberty he was going to have to come
to a kind of recognition of his own
worth he was told that by design of God
he was to be a slave he also had to come
to a kind of spiritual awakening as
Frederick testified this spirit this
awakening within him made me a free man
in fact though I still remained a slave
in form in other words he was still
enslaved in body
he still had to endure that existence
but the stirrings that had happened in
his heart had readied him for the
Liberty that he soon would win he gained
what Alexander Solzhenitsyn the great
Russian dissident called a point of view
that point of view that says a tyranny
cannot lay claim to your soul that they
might be able to have claimed to your
body that they might be able to turn
eyes your day-to-day activities but
ultimately they can't have who you are
who you really are now what Douglas
resolved to do at this point was to
resist the predations of this slave
breaker this man liked particularly to
lie in wait so that once Douglas did one
little thing wrong in the day he would
jump out leap on him and beat him half
to death and the day that Douglas
resolved that he would no longer take
this he said he would resist it in
physical form now of course by this
point he was a strong man and he could
have put down that guy probably but when
that guy left out at him and Douglas
resisted putting of course his life in
an greater threat the slave breaker
called upon everybody around him the
other slaves people that were working
for him to come to his aid none did
Douglas had resisted him successfully
and after that he was never touched by
that man again it took him another six
months before he gained his Liberty
before he escaped before he ran away but
once he did then he was on his way to
becoming one of America's greatest
orators and indeed statesmen he was
discovered by William Lloyd Garrison an
abolitionist he rose to prominence he
became one of America's leading
journalists he spoke all over the
country including twice on the campus of
Hillsdale College people sometimes
doubted whether Douglas had ever been
enslaved they said he was to articulate
to have been enslaved and he replied if
you don't believe me you can see the
Diploma that's written on my back
Douglas came to a place of real
prominence in this
nation his advocacy was a on behalf of
all who were oppressed and he came to a
dilemma that i think has some relevance
for us today this is the dilemma do you
stand on the Constitution of the United
States do you say that the
constitutional foundations those humble
foundations that Madison made that they
are worth standing on and that they'll
be the means by which slavery could be
ended or do you say with William Lloyd
Garrison that the Constitution was a
compact with the devil that it was a
blood-soaked covenant that it was
something that was so corrupt you
couldn't have anything to do with the
question was whether you ought to engage
in politics pursue political compromise
or abandoning all of that insist upon a
purity that called the Constitution
bankrupt early in his career Douglas was
part of the Garas onian school later he
came to the place where Lincoln was
insisting that the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution were
our only sure foundation for putting
slavery on course of ultimate extinction
he came to this realization in one very
pregnant and dramatic moment but he
handled it this announcement this break
from his fellows the people who had
discovered him William Lloyd Garrison
and the garrison ians by announcing in
his newspaper change of opinion after
two years plus of soul-searching Douglas
now believed that the Constitution was
an anti-slavery document and he was able
to address his fellow citizens as just
that fellow citizens before that time he
wondered was this country was this
country's founding worth defending but
what he came to in this kind of link
onian recognition of the goodness and
greatness of our founding was that he
had something to stand on as he fought
slavery in 1860 Douglas said this here I
quote what then is the Constitution
it is no vague indefinite floating
unsubstantial ideal something colored
according to any man's fancy now a
weasel now a whale and now nothing three
years after that time a Douglas was on
the campus of Hillsdale College best as
we can tell he gave a speech that
focused on two figures William Lloyd
Garrison and Abraham Lincoln the date
was the third week of January 1863 the
Emancipation Proclamation had just come
into effect can you imagine what that
meant for Frederick Douglass that thing
for which he had worked hard so
arduously fought for and here he was
giving recognition to Lincoln for this
mammoth accomplishment that in order for
Lincoln to do he had to stand nearly as
a party of one the siege from every side
when Douglas spoke in the at the
dedication of the Lincoln statue that is
not not but a mile from here at Lincoln
Park he reflected upon the goodness and
greatness of Abraham Lincoln when he
spoke at that on the campus of Hillsdale
College one of the things that he said
is a single individual armed with truth
is a majority against the world so back
to today what do Madison and Douglas
teach us about humility and healthy
pride I think we have before us a
challenge to recover a sense of pride in
our nation's history recognizing that
return to founding principles does not
mean the abandonment of progress in fact
it's the best means of assuring the kind
of progress that matters most this is
not progress with a capital P the kind
of progress where you're trying to get
on the right side of history it's not
the kind of progress that has been
pushed for the last 100 years by
progressives but a very different idea
the founders talked quite a lot
Washington included about the idea of
progress the possibility of human
achievement humility isn't a dour
and downward thing it's not self
despising it's not self debasement what
it does is tempers one one's ambition it
makes one more realistic about the
possibilities but it certainly doesn't
act as a depressant to human achievement
to regain the proper humility about our
national purpose we have to come to a
better sense of what government's role
should be in our lives for I think one
of the main ways that we see arrogance
around us all today using the kind of
omni competence of Washington DC the
purported Omni competence that it can do
everything and that if it can't do
everything all that we need is a little
bit of a kind of technical fix they're
just glitches on the road to history
with a capital H or progress with the
capital p I have here Forbes is most
recent recent issue it just came out
with its most powerful people the big
news was that Vladimir Putin is ranked
number one and President Obama number
two but if you look to the way that they
introduce this list of 72 they explain
why they came up with that number there
are seven point two billion people on
the planet these are the 72 who matter
now in writing a book extolling the
recovery of humility I don't expect that
we'll see a list of the most humble
leaders any time soon as Franklin might
have reminded us that would kind of
defeat the purpose but it's not the case
that there are 72 people who matter on
the planet the people who matter on this
planet are the people who are on this
planet our cause Benjamin Franklin said
is the cause of all nations the
exceptional thing about America is that
the promise of liberty and equality for
all is rooted in a humility about human
nature it's combined with the confidence
in the possibilities for human
achievement greatness of soul guides the
gaze of individuals to the heights
humility issues a warning against flying
too high
there's no guarantee though of national
greatness the arrogance of our age
supposes that prosperity is perpetual
and that success is inevitable America's
history of hard-won humility and healthy
pride tells us otherwise as individuals
and it's a people we would do well to
rediscover our greatest virtue thank
thanks very much I think we have a tight
time for a few questions or objections
yes Milton you know I I quit watching
the Olympics a few years back because I
got so embarrassed when the American
teams would carry on like totally
boastful arrogant winners and when they
lost a bunch of spoiled children whereas
other countries you know we're well
behaved and so you talked about his
American virtue I feel like it once upon
a time it was but I begin to wonder but
um do you feel like there's a religious
component to it because humility is of
course a Christian virtue is not a pagan
virtue and in a post-christian world you
know you you worship well your trip
yourself what what's your thought about
the religious component to a revival of
humility in America is as their one I
think there certainly is one of the the
touchstones of ah i think this question
about humility and greatness is
precisely as you mentioned the
difference between the christian
conception of the virtue and it's
notable absence from from many of the
the ancient classical positions you know
in Aristotle's depiction of the
magnanimous man you don't see anything
quite resembling humility and you might
think of it this way he gives a kind of
portrait of the magnanimous man this
person that is great and knows that he's
great right right off the bat that
doesn't sound like somebody that the
ta's is particularly humble the ancients
were eminently aware of the problem of
hubris and the Revenge of Nemesis right
so they were not in any way saying that
an unhealthy pride could work at all
it's just very hard to imagine for
example the magnanimous man stooping to
wash the feet of those around him or
doing what today Pope Francis did with
that man who had the diff not deformed
face right embracing him kissing that
kissing that man who had been a kind of
outcast throughout his life right that's
the kind of thing that the Christian
idea of mercy clemency and compare
which literally means to suffer with
brings and I think there's a lot of that
kind of leavening that came into the
American Founding because the American
Founding is a kind of combination of
that aspiration to greatness along the
Aristotelian terms combined with the
idea that we ought to be and must be a
good people in order to be great and
there's a tension though and that
theoretical tension i think has an
imperfect resolution in theory right
Aquinas tried to bring it to a kind of
place where he said look humility and
magnanimity are twins and there's a way
in which you could make that argument
but the theoretical ear resolution finds
a kind of interesting counterpart in
reality for the five figures and perhaps
there's more I just focused on on five
combined in their own Souls humility and
greatness and that's a really rare thing
it's extraordinarily rare that you can
find individuals that have that
combination and I think that that in
each their own way George Washington
Abby Adams James Madison and Lincoln and
Frederick Douglass did that thing yes
Jeff building on that question from
Elton was alexander the great great well
you know it's indisputable that when
you've done what he did by the age of 33
you've accomplished something almost
literally unparalleled in history
probably unparalleled when lincoln as a
young man not yet 30 is making a speech
in Springfield Illinois about the
perpetuation of our political
institutions he pointed to the example
of Alexander as somebody that would
disdain the beaten path right there's no
way that Alexander the Great is ever
going to sat be satisfied with running
for a city council seat right this guy
has global aspirations right and he was
only going to be satisfied by conquests
what's greater though than Alexander the
Great that's the question that Lincoln
was asking in this speech even as a
young man could you free the slaves or
enslave free man he looked at those as
the two alternatives and he looked back
to George Washington as far greater than
any other figure in ancient history
because George Washington might have
done it very differently in fact it
wouldn't have been surprising at all had
Washington when been when he was granted
twice the powers literally of a dictator
during the Revolutionary War had not
abided by the strictures thrown them off
become dictator for life right the
founders did not have a high regard most
of them for Caesar but rather for Brutus
and Cassius right they were Liberty
lovers they worried in that regard about
the kind of Roman Republic their main
preoccupation and the reason that
Washington I think really earned the
title of American Cincinnatus was how do
you make sure that their project our
project doesn't degenerate into Empire
and if you can pull that off you would
be the greatest of all but you'd be
great for the right reasons right not
conquest but Liberty yes David oh you
mentioned in your book pride is not the
opposite of humility would you explain
right so i think the the sort of
caricature of humility insofar as we
think of it today we think of it as this
kind of insipid week thing you know
people that are successful would never
be humble because you have to give up so
much right Kanye West ah the noted
philosopher said you know why is
everybody telling us to be humble what
about being amazing by that he meant
there they're opposites right and I
think that's the way most people think
if you're humble your
to be you know kind of quiet shy
retiring basically you're going to get
rolled over by everybody else and so I
think that humility is not that it
actually does have a real strength to it
but it cannot be devoid of pride right
pride in and of itself is something that
does come naturally to us right humility
does not mean if you watch a little kid
the first time that they roll over and
finally have that first time that they
they sit up they look like they've just
done the most amazing thing on the
planet and they look around to you until
you look back at them and give them that
look or tell them we're so proud of you
right they want that kind of recognition
we and some of that recognition is
healthy you can have a proper pride in
other words you can't have a proper
arrogance pride can run a mock it can go
too far and I think that's the challenge
that we have with patriotism it's the
challenge that we have in a lot of areas
of life how do you rein in the pride so
that it's healthy a lot of times today
Americans don't know why they love their
country and we've kind of lost our
patriotic got spirit sure there's the
Kitsch and the you know the fourth of
July stuff but you know we don't really
know what we're celebrating presidents
day right we around our classrooms you
ring all of the pictures of every
president as if they've all been equal
so I think that I hope that goes to
answering your question that healthy
pride that thing that Madison and for
that matter Frederick Douglass both had
to discover is just as important as that
humility we have time for one last
question would certainly David I applaud
the work that you do here at kirby
center and hillsdale for intellectually
making the case for humility and for
intellectual strength and integrity in
America I think of humility also being a
spiritual virtue how do we r Ian still
that back into the culture so that it
becomes a cultural renewal as you said
not a not a regression not not a Looking
Backward but that prospective cultural
influence and have that kind of a
dynamic impact in America right I think
one of the first steps if one is to try
to become humble both as a either as an
individual or insofar as it's possible
as a people is to recognize that we're
not self created there has to be
something beyond the autonomous I beyond
that ego that we see so much paraded
online but in every other facet of our
life right the Declaration of
Independence speaks intentionally about
the idea of a Creator God and that
implies by necessity that we are
creatures and that's not a demeaning
place that's not a humiliated place it
is a place rather where one can
recognize if you're not your own
lawgiver if there are such things as the
laws of nature and of nature's God then
there's something besides your own
internal conscience we've been looking
at with with my class this the semester
at various virtues that that might be
necessary for statesmanship and we
talked a little bit about the idea of
conscience today when there's a vote of
conscience on the hill it means that all
debate stops we just lay that trump card
down and you say this is a vote of
conscience all arguments tops and so
we've gone to the place where
somehow we've taken any hint of religion
to mean that debate and reason stops so
I think part of the the recovery hear of
a spiritual sense of humility
paradoxically enough is recovery of
reason faith and reason working together
that's the way that the founders put
things and it's the way that we will I
think be most effective in winning over
our fellow citizens but there is that
recognition that deep recognition once
you take that step and say there's a
creator there's probably then a god that
the tie is more active in your in your
life and I think that's where Washington
found himself I think that's certainly
where Lincoln found himself late in life
you know he had a deepening of his of
his faith God was inscrutable in some
ways right you couldn't pinpoint exactly
why he was doing what he was and the
purpose was never for Washington or
Lincoln to invoke God and say well we
have God on our side now we will go do
XY and z the quest was rather and I
think this is this really bespeaks their
humility is to figure out how can we be
on the side of the Divine thanks much
thank you and thank you David for that
wonderful talk I now invite you to a
reception in our opening our entry hall
where David will be signing books and
he's far too humble but I will say you
can buy books and remember that
Christmas is around the corner thank you
all for coming have a nice evening